[Musique]
on vient croyez vous qu'il y ait de
papus ne faut trop de quoi voter bien
sur vos droits
ward a passé ils ont manqué
[Musique]
canfin tête ben tu as peur tu as perdu
ton nouveau kong est aussi pif gmic et
monsieur gogo la guinée aux hôtels bars
[Musique]
invités monsieur bongo ont fait que tu
es mon aile je bourre on va encore nous
dire mon temps tout était bien dans mon
train tous les la cataracte un gentil
même temps on est moins bruyant pas un
truc de pata truc j'ai trouvé le truc le
trou vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir
bon on n'y est pas une
mais toi là devant le micro
eric fait pas un micro si c'est mon
micro ri j'ai pas vu le second ce lundi
ne s'est pas drôle hein pas d'accord ça
tue le pij alaoui châteaulin je veux
qu'ils rient voila voila c'est
enregistré à toi et moi on n'enregistre
pas c'est fait tu as rien même table
pata du riz pâtes à tarte main pour toi
à mes chers amis de mon temps qu'est ce
que c'est quoi donc qu'est ce que c'est
mais vous n'avez pas entendu des rires
des rires non vous avez entendu derrière
vos autres j'ai dû manger trop de
gâteaux olivier monsieur bougon de
montant mais vous avez entendu cette
fois sac à papier
j'aurais juré que y'a personne à la
cuisine ou dans les champs non pourquoi
mais vous êtes sur wii
reprenons notre conversation cher
monsieur bougon oui oui je ne sais plus
où nous en étions assis devant une
couche et je me sens pas bien
et pourtant de mon temps je crois que
nous l'avons guéri il ne dira plus de
l'otan en à toi papa cloud via mon topo
mais la peur est mauvaise posture
[Rires]
quand fisker
[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait deux
papas plus jeunes eux
photo epa comptait bien sur vos doigts
témoin d'un parcours attention il lui
manque
[Musique]